welcome to the presentation on units
let's get started so if I were to ask
you or if I were to say I have traveled
let's say I've traveled point zero five
kilometers
some people say kilometres kilometers if
I have traveled point zero five
kilometers how many centimetres have I
traveled those question mark centimeters
so before we break into the math it's
important to just know what these
prefixes centi and kilo mean and it's
good to memorize this or when you're
first starting to do these problems you
can just write them down a piece of
paper just you have a reference so kilo
kilo means a thousand hecto means 100
deca means ten you might recognize that
from decade ten years and then of course
you have no prefix means one no prefix
no prefix equals one deci is equal to
0.1 or 1/10 senti keep changing between
cases centi is equal to point zero 1 or
1 over 100 and then milli is equal to
point zero zero 1 and it's the same
thing as 1 over a thousand and the way I
remember I mean is sent to senti if you
think of a centipede has 100 feet a
millipede I'm not sure if a millipede
has a thousand feet but but that's the
implication when someone says a
millipede because peed means feet so
let's go back to the problem if I have
point zero five kilometers how many
centimeters do I have so whenever I do a
problem like this I like to actually
convert my number to meters because
that's very
for me and actually I'm going to
abbreviate this as km and we can
abbreviate this as cm 4 centimeters so
let's say point 0 5 km well if I want to
convert this into meters is it going to
be more than point 0 5 meters or less
than point zero 5 meters well they're a
kilometer is a very large distance so in
terms of meters it's going to be a much
bigger number so we can multiply this
times 1000 meters and I'll do it over
1/4 kilometer and what does that get
well 0.05 times 1,000 is equal to 50 all
right I just multiplied point O five
times 1,000 and with the unit's I now
have kilometers times meters over
kilometers and the kilometers cancel out
and and just so you're familiar with
this you can treat units exactly the
same way that you would treat numbers or
variables as long if you have the same
unit in the U numerator and the
denominator you can cancel them out
assuming that they're not adding units
you're multiplying units so you have
kilometers times meters divided by
kilometers and that equals 50 meters and
it's good to always do a reality check
after every step usually when you do
this type of problems you know okay if I
want to go from kilometers to meters I'm
going to use that the number of thousand
because that's the relationship between
a kilometer nanometer and you're always
confused well do I multiply it by a
thousand or do I divide by a thousand
and you always have to say well if I'm
going from kilometers to meters I'm
going 1 kilometers a thousand meters
right so I'm going to be multiplying by
a so I'm going to get a bigger number so
that's why I went from 0.05 and I'm
multiplied it by a thousand and I got 50
so let's get back to the problem point
oh five kilometers is equal to 50 meters
we're not done yet now I need to convert
those 50 meters into centimeters well we
do the same thing 50 meters
times how many so so what's the
relationship between meters and
centimeters well if we look at the chart
we see it's 100 and the question I'm
going to ask you I'm going to multiply
by 100 or am I going to divide by 100
what's the same thing we're going from a
bigger unit to a smaller unit so one of
a bigger unit is equal to a bunch of the
smaller unit so we're going to multiply
so we see times 100 centimeters per
metre right and that just makes sense
there's 100 centimeters per meter so 50
meters times 100 centimeters per meter
is equal to 50 times 100 is five
thousand five thousand and then the
meters cancel out and you get
centimeters so we have here is the point
zero five kilometers is equals is equal
to five thousand centimeters let's do
another problem I think the more
examples you see it'll make a little
more sense and I always try to visualize
what we're doing the scale otherwise
it's very confusing whether you should
multiply or divide let's say I have 422
decigrams grams are a measure of mass
it's very one gram is actually a very
small amount that's you measure I guess
in the metric system they measure gold
in terms of grams and I want to convert
this into milligrams so before we start
the problem let's just do a reality
check
am I going from a bigger unit to a
smaller unit or a small unit a bigger
unit well deci grams that's that's 1/10
of a gram and I'm going to one one
thousandth of a gram so there's two ways
of doing this we can convert to grams
and then convert to the other unit that
sometimes makes things easy or we could
say well how many milligrams is equal to
one decigram well a milligram as we see
here is a hundred times smaller right to
go from 110 to one over a thousand you
have to decrease in size 500 so we could
just say 422 decigrams
times 100 milligrams per deciliter
a hundred that's forty two thousand two
hundred milligrams
now another way you could have done it
is the way we just did that last problem
we could say 422 decigrams we could
convert that to grams so we could say
422 I'm just going to say DG so that's
not really a familiar unit decigrams and
how many decigrams are there per gram
and if we're going to gram we're going
to get 4 and 22 is going to be a smaller
number of grams right so we could say x
1 decigram is equal to how many grams
well 1 decigram is equal to I'm sorry
1 gram is how equal to how many
decigrams well 1 gram is equal to 10
that's a gram and the reason why this
makes sense is if we have a decigram in
the numerator here we want to decigram
in the denominator here so if we have
decigrams cancel out so 422 decigrams
will equal that divided by 10 is equal
to 42 0.2 grams and now we could just go
from grams to milligrams well that's an
easy one 1 gram is equal to a thousand
milligrams so we could say times 1000
milligram per gram the grams cancel out
and we're left with 42,000 200
milligrams right 42.2 times 1000
hopefully that doesn't confuse you too
much the important thing is to always
take a step back and really visualize
and think about should I be getting a
larger number or a smaller number than
the one I started off with I think
you're ready to now try some problems
have fun